engagement pour la solidarité
l'environnement lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes une partie
des causes défendues par die et diakité
ce plaisir roi et président de
l'association mali les moon ou des
nombreuses actions solidaires sont
menées elles se sont multipliées
aujourd'hui à cause de la crise
sanitaire
beaucoup de gens de la classe moyenne
nécessite une aide alimentaire et gêne
aujourd'hui ce qui fait que les actions
de l'association se sont multipliés
naturellement en fait donc il ya plus de
besoin donc voilà on essaie quand même
dd comme on peut ces femmes il a mal il
est mou nous est aussi engagé dans les
pays en voie de développement un soutien
est apporté aux orphelins du mali une
aide humanitaire aussi aux populations
vulnérables en france c'était le cas en
décembre 2010 9 près de 1200 tibétains
ont bénéficié du soutien de
l'association notamment lorsqu'ils ont
été accueillis à villepreux le coeur des
actions de deuil et diakité reste à
plaisir au quartier du vélib ouf c'est
le quartier où j'ai grandi
c'est un quartier qui m'a qui ment à
tout donner donc voilà aujourd'hui quand
on parle de die et on parle avant tout
de ce quartier là on parle de on parle
du valais bout avant tout on arrive à
produire aujourd'hui avec l'association
manier les mots no c'est clairement ce
que le quartier
nous a offert et nous a appris depuis
l'enfance le plus important pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est le facteur humain à
partir du moment où on est humain on a
besoin de l'autre on a besoin de se
sentir utile d'aider les personnes
nécessiteuses
c'est vraiment c'est quelque chose à
vivre et c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
peut pas y a pas de mots pour expliquer
ce qu'on ressent quand on est des gens
en plus de son association d'ail et
diakité dirige la société west africa
distribution spécialisée dans le
transport en france et au mali pour les
particuliers et les professionnels
gérer l'ensemble de ses activités une
mission parfois compliqué ce qui efface
n pour moi c'est d'avoir un entourage
comme mes amis qui sont là aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on avec nous et à moi mais
j'aime ça quand je suis pas là je suis
en train de gérer les affaires sont là
derrière en train de gérer l'association
beaucoup de projets sont en cours de
développement exemple avec
l'organisation d'un challenge autour de
la lutte contre les déchets plastiques
lancée prochainement